well hello and welcome to class friends
and family my name is idalia denzi and
it's a privilege for me to spend this
hour with you studying the word of God
many of you have sent in your questions
your comments and we thank you from the
bottom of our hearts you know it's
exciting to look forward to class I
don't know if that happened to you Jason
Bradley
it definitely didn't used to happen but
I am excited about it today praise the
Lord and I know you at home are anxious
to see the questions that are going to
be addressed during this hour but I want
to invite you to just grab your bible
grab something to write with and
something to write on because these
questions might be the very same ones
that have been you've been pondering on
so without further Ado I'm going to
present my family here in Christ from
3abn Jason Bradley as you greeted
already welcome our friends to here oh
look I'm excited to be here I'm excited
to learn and you know today I'm excited
to be in class
Shelly Quinn
we thank you for hosting today and thank
you for sending in your questions it's
always fun for us to delve into the word
and do our best to answer them in a
short period of time a short period of
time is right but and then it's my
privilege to labor for the Lord with my
husband John Dempsey welcome
thank you so much it's a blessing to be
here and to participate with the family
here at Caribbean amen well praise the
Lord that you are here too and you know
we would like for you to
um join us in prayer because we want the
Holy Spirit to impress our hearts open
our ears our eyes our hearts to the word
of God this is from the word of God it's
not our opinion that we're going to be
sharing so let's pray together father
God in Jesus name we approach your
throne of grace thank you for your
invitation to come to you you have all
the answers your life Lord there are
questions that are lingering in our
minds we're Curiosity has come into our
hearts and we'd like to know the truth
about these things so we ask your father
to direct impress our hearts and be with
our presenters today answering these
questions in a special way be with our
viewing family and radio listeners who
are also seeking
Truth Bible truth and I pray father that
this will bring life to them and
encouragement in Jesus name amen and
amen amen okay so taking care of
business Jason we have to share the
contact information because we want to
hear from you you are the most important
part of the program because these are
your questions in your comments so we
invite you to send your texts to
1-618-228-3975 that's
1-618-228-3975 and you can write to us
in Instagram social media Instagram is
3abn underscore official that's 3abn
underscore official in Instagram and you
can send us your emails at bibleqa at
3abn.tv bible QA at 3abn.tv and you know
what just as the programming is 24 hours
so it's the email so there's no hour too
late for you to send in your comments
and emails right
all right team are you ready ready all
right we're going to start off with
Jason Bradley and it's a blessing to
receive these emails this is the comment
and question we have recently I have had
discussions with people who tend to be
logical so can logic compare to Faith or
where does logic fall compared to Faith
that's an excellent question and you
know I want to share a brief
illustration with you there was a man
and he was talking with an atheist and
he handed The Atheist a book and he told
the atheist to flip through the book and
so as the atheist was flipping through
the book he said what do you see the
atheist said I see letters and he said
what do those letters come together to
form and he The Atheist answered him and
he said words okay and then the words
come together and they form what
sentences and those sentences form
paragraphs and the point is they form
cohesive thoughts well how did those
letters and those words and everything
come together to form cohesive thoughts
there was an author that put it in there
and so then the man asked the atheist he
said
do you think that this book is more
complex than the human body and the
atheist said no the the human body is
more complex than the book
and it was like you know that should
show you logically that we have a
creator
and um so an answer to your question the
Bible does not explicitly address the
relationship between logic and faith in
the way that these concepts are
discussed in modern day philosophy
however there are Bible verses that
touch on related themes that can be
interpreted in the context of the
question here are a few verses faith in
God okay Proverbs chapter 3 verses 5 to
6 says trust in the Lord with all your
heart and lean not on your understanding
in all your ways acknowledge Him and He
Shall direct your paths faith in God
should take precedence over relying
solely on one's own understanding or
logic First Corinthians chapter 1 verses
18 through 21. it says for the message
of the Cross is foolishness to those who
are perishing but to us who are being
saved it is the power of God for it is
written I will destroy the wisdom of the
the wise and bring to nothing the
understanding of The Prudent where is
the wise where is the Scribe where is
the disputer of this age has not God
made foolish the wisdom of the world for
since in the wisdom of God the world
through wisdom did not know God it
pleased God through the foolishness of
the message preached to save those who
believe Isaiah chapter 55 verses 8 and 9
for my thoughts are not your thoughts
nor are your ways my way says the Lord
for as the heavens are higher than the
earth so are my thoughts so are my ways
higher than your ways and my thoughts
than your thoughts Divine wisdom
surpasses human understanding implying
that Faith requires trusting in God's
higher perspective Romans chapter 10
verse 17 says so then faith comes by
hearing and here hearing by the word of
God faith is nurtured through hearing
and receiving the word of God which
involves both spiritual and rational
elements we can go up to a point with
logic but then Faith must kick in in our
Christian Journey faith is vitally
important Hebrews chapter 11 verse 6
says but without faith it is impossible
to please him for he who comes to God
must believe that he is and that he is a
rewarder of those who diligently seek
him you know I like to think of Faith as
the ability to tolerate uncertainty
while trusting in God so we need to rely
on our faith in God some people will
reason their way out of everything and
the one thing you don't want to reason
your way out of is trusting in the Lord
amen amen praise the Lord praise God now
the next question thank you Jason now we
received an email from Matthew and this
question I'm going to address Shelley
with it over the years I have learned
that prayer is not about us moving God
God but God changing us yet there are
many examples in the Bible where people
have been able to seemingly move God's
hand is their tangible value in praying
for people who are sick or otherwise in
need of divine assistance Matthew sent
that in uh email that's a great question
and here's what I will say the only
portion of our prayer that doesn't
really move God or change God I always
begin my prayer with praise God is not
changed by our praised or moved but it
does change us however intercession
supplication
definitely releases God's power His
blessings on Earth James 4 will look at
verse 2 the B section says you do not
have because you do not ask and then he
goes on and says you ask and don't
receive because you ask amiss with wrong
motives that you may spend it on your
pleasures James 5 16 and 17. this is
from the Amplified the earnest heartfelt
continued prayer of a righteous man
makes tremendous power available dynamic
in its working Elijah was a human being
with a nature such as we have with
feelings and affections and a
constitution like ours and he prayed
earnestly for it not to Reign and no
rain fell on the earth for three years
and six months Hebrews 4 16. says let us
come boldly to the throne of grace that
we might receive mercy and Grace in our
time of need
Jesus prayed it didn't change Jesus he
was praying in submission to God's will
but he teaches us to pray for God's will
to be done not only in our lives but in
other people's lives God will not force
his will God has there are blessings
waiting in the wings promises that are
ready to be ushered in by faith and
prayer is part of Faith Isaiah 59 verse
16 says this
be God
saw that there was no man and wondered
that there was no intercessor God is
looking down on the earth and he's
wondering why no one cares enough to
pray for others why no one trusts and
believes that he will answer prayer see
our role as intercessors is actually
part of God's plan to bring down His
blessings from heaven we were created to
be co-intercessors with Christ and
intercessory prayer is the highest
calling Ministry there is because it is
the ministry of Our Risen and exalted
savior so we are conformed to Jesus
image as we pray for others it's our
duty and I'm going to end with this
thought
neglecting to pray for others neglecting
to get God to release His blessings
could be the very reason that God's work
on Earth is not
finished wow that is a strong statement
it is yes wow praise the Lord so be
encouraged and let us all pray for one
another we can all use prayers praise
the Lord thank you Shelley John Dempsey
you are next and this is a text that
came in and it says if Jesus and John
the Baptist were cousins why did John
ask Jesus are you the one
thank you for the question it's very
interesting question and I think I like
to go first to John chapter 1. and
beginning verse 32 to
go into this answer it says and John
boar witness saying I saw the Spirit
descending from heaven like a dove and
he remained upon Him referring to Jesus
I did not know him
but he who sent me to baptize with water
said to me upon whom you see the spirit
descending and remaining on him this is
he who baptizes with the Holy Spirit it
is apparent by these words that John the
Baptist was not aware that Jesus would
be the Messiah until this sign was
fulfilled notice verse 34 and I have
seen and testified that this is the Son
of God it's very interesting also that
as you consider John the Baptist as you
said that they were cousins they were
about six months apart and God also
protected John the Baptist remember the
Herod when the wise men came asking for
where is he that is born King of the
Jews
when the wise men did not return to
Herod
he made a declaration that all the
children two years and under should be
destroyed John the Baptist was two years
and under and the Lord preserved his
life because there was a special mission
for him now something happens to John
because he testified that
he is the one he is the Messiah and this
is why now we go to Luke chapter 7 and
verse 19 and 20. notice what happens and
John calling two of his disciples to him
sent them to Jesus saying are you the
coming one or do we look for another
when the men had come to him they said
John the Baptist has sent to us you to
you saying are you the one coming or do
we look for another so they came asking
are you the one so it appears that as
John was in prison uh and not seeing
Jesus not hearing that Jesus was doing
what he thought Jesus should be doing
his idea was that Jesus would take the
people of Israel and once again restore
the kingdom to Israel and they would be
the head and not the tale and Jesus was
not doing that so he's beginning to
wonder is he really the one are you
really the one so this uh question he
sent to Jesus and Jesus sent him a a
rebuke he told his disciples Baptist
disciples go and tell John that the
blind received their sight the lame walk
and the lepers are cleansed Etc et
cetera et cetera and they went back with
this message a message that John
understood that yes
I am the one and John believed we don't
have a lot of information as to his
reaction but the message was clear to
John a little rebuke but also to
understand that uh what you have heard
uh concerning me is true and that his
kingdom is not one Jesus did not come to
this world to set up an Earthly Kingdom
his mission was just as he lived it he
came and lived a perfect life died for
every one of us so that we could have
the opportunity for salvation his
kingdom On Earth Is Yet future amen amen
very good thank you John now we have the
next question and we want to encourage
you all to send in your comments and
questions to the program as well we're
going to share the contact information
in a little bit but let's go to the next
text and that was received so Jason
Bradley what do you think about
cremation and a sleep in the grave huh
the short answer is it's a personal
choice it's not a sin for you to be
cremated uh or buried either way but
it's okay for a Christian to choose
cremation over a casket burial nowhere
in the Bible does it mention that
cremation is forbidden last time I
answered this question I got quite a few
interesting emails and we're always
thankful to hear from you but I want to
preface my my statement or my my answer
through the following statements or with
the following statements whether we're
cremated or buried we serve a powerful
God that can put us back together and he
doesn't need our skeletal structure to
do so
our God speaks and things come into
existence cremation simply accelerates
the decomposition process now a person
that is buried ends up turning into dust
as their body decomposes it just takes
longer if we're both traveling to a
store and I I choose to drive maybe it's
10 minutes away and you choose to walk
that's definitely your choice I'm going
to get to the store faster we'll both
get there but I'll get there faster it's
the same thing with cremation and burial
the person that chooses to get cremated
they're just accelerating the
decomposition process one of the first
examples of cremation that I've seen in
the Bible can be found in first Samuel
chapter 31 verses 11 through 13.
now when the inhabitants of jabesh
Gilead heard what the Philistines had
done to Saul all the Valiant men arose
and traveled all night and took the body
of Saul and the bodies of his sons from
the wall of Beth Shan and they came to
jabesh and burned them there then they
took their bones and buried them under
the tamarisk tree at jabish and fasted
seven days now there are a few things
for us to consider number one Genesis
chapter 3 verse 19. in the sweat of your
face you shall eat bread till you return
to the ground for out of it you were
taken for dust you are and dust you
shall return
Ecclesiastes chapter 3 verse 20. all go
to one place all from are from the dust
and all returned to dust and number
three First Corinthians chapter 15
verses 51-53 says behold I tell you a
mystery we shall not all sleep but we
shall all be changed in a moment in the
twinkling of an eye at the last trumpet
for the trumpet will sound and the dead
will be raised Incorruptible and we
shall be changed for this corruptable
must put on incorruption and this Mortal
must put on immortality so whether you
want to be cremated or buried in the
casket either way is fine it's a
personal choice it is not a sin to be
cremated if you find in the Bible which
you won't because it's not there that it
is a sin by all means send me an email
amen thank you very much A lot of people
have that same question and that person
that sent in that text you represent
that community so praise the Lord thank
you Jason Shelley Quinn are you ready
for your next question okay it says here
we received this from Georgia it's a
text that came in from Georgia it
doesn't have a name but it says can you
explain first John 5 16 and 17 what is
sin not unto death okay what is a sin
not unto death let's look at the context
of this we will begin with first John 5
14 and 15 which gives us context now
this is the confidence that we have in
him that if we ask anything according to
his will he hears us and if we know he
hears us whatever we ask we know that we
have the petitions that we have ask of
him that's context
then it goes on first John 5 16 and 17.
if anyone sees his brother sending a
sandwich does not lead to death he will
ask in confidence and he will give him
Life For Those who commit sin not
leading to death there is sin leading to
death I do not say that he should we he
should pray about that then he says all
unrighteousness is sin
and there is sin not leading to death
there's only you know we think of sin as
major and minor sins God sees all sin as
deserving of death that's all sin if
there's only two categories of sin in
God's eyes there's sin that we confess
and we repent of and first John 1 9 says
that he is faithful and just to forgive
us our sins and cleanse us of all
unrighteousness the second category is
of sin that is not confessed that is not
repented of and that leads to spiritual
death which will eventually lead to
death he's talking here that if you see
a brother he's talking about a Christian
who's aware of sin and has passed back
over from spiritual life to spiritual
death and we just have to know that
John's not commanding us to pray either
way here he's not saying we can't pray
for those but the the bottom line is we
have no confidence in our prayers if God
won't Force his will on someone if a man
will not confess his sins our prayer for
him will not be efficacious that's right
and you know it's beautiful that we can
ask the Lord to remind us of those sins
that we have committed to bring us to
our memory so we can repent so there
will be nothing between me and my savior
so we stand firm in the word of God and
his promises because he fulfills them
amen John Dempsey are you ready for
yours by God's grace okay it says here
we Sharon sent in an email and it says
can you explain why the Turning of the
wine into water is referred to as
Jesus's first miracle when he helped
Simon Peter and Andrew catch a boatload
of fish was that not his first miracle
and if not why Sharon wants to know
thank you Sharon for the question is
very interesting that you're wondering
about this this is interesting because
it says in John chapter 2 verse 11 this
beginning of miracles did Jesus in Cana
of Galilee and manifested forth his
glory and his disciples believed on him
so this is what we are working with and
the beginning the word beginning here is
is a it's a Greek word RK which means
beginning or first place or being in
what you would call a headship or
leadership so here we're asking
ourselves why is this called the first
miracle uh did not Jesus do other
miracles
if this is not the first miracle we must
understand that this is his first public
Ministry Miracle the way Mary approached
him it appears that he believed that he
could do a miracle and Jesus pretty much
kept what you would might call a low
profile when he was young and this is
why when we go to Mark chapter 6 verse 2
and 3 we have this declaration it says
and when the Sabbath had come he began
to teach in the synagogue and many
hearing him were astonished saying where
did this man get these things and what
wisdom is this which is given to him
that such Mighty works are performed by
his hands it's not this the carpetent
the carpenter the son of Mary and the
brother of James Joseph Judas and Simon
are not all his sisters here with us so
they were offended him so apparently in
the community that he lived while he was
young Jesus was not doing any Miracles
because now they are seeing miracles in
this particular passage in Mark chapter
six and they are amazed because if this
is the carpenter why why is he doing
miracles so Jesus kept a low profile and
upon the time of his ministry remember
that when Mary came to him he says my
hour is not yet come in other words it's
not time for me to to start doing
Miracles publicly so this is a first
miracle that he did publicly in essence
when you're talking about the one about
the boatload of fishes how many people
were there a few and maybe just the
disciples so it was not a public a
public Miracle among a lot of people so
this is why they're saying the beginning
of America the beginning of his uh
public Ministry so this is uh something
we can consider as we ask ourselves this
question very good thank you so much now
we will go to the next comment here we
received this through Instagram and
Jason Bradley this one's for you and you
know what so many people can
um identify with his question anyway is
it okay to pray with music in the
background I'm talking about music with
no lyrics Just instruments I have had a
hard time praying when all I hear is an
awkward silence I'm wondering if I need
to stop or continue the music
all right great question the Bible
doesn't provide specific guidance on
whether you can or cannot pray with
instrumental music in the background
however it does offer principles that
can help you make a decision based on
your personal relationship with God and
your own conscience here are some verses
and principles to consider and another
thing that I want you to consider before
we go to those verses is the fact that
when you go to church what happens
during the congregational prayer what
are they playing they're playing music
and people are praying with music in the
in the background as well but Psalm
chapter 150 verses 3 to 5. praise him
with the sound of the trumpet praise him
with the loot and harp praise him with
the timbrel and dance praise him with
stringed instruments and flutes praise
him with loud symbols praise him with
clashing symbols this Psalm encourages
the use of various instruments in praise
and worship which can be applied to the
use of instrumental music in prayer as
well first Corinthians chapter 10 verse
31 this is a great principle for us to
embrace First Corinthians chapter 10
verse 31 therefore whether you eat or
drink or whatever you do do all to the
glory of God if listening to
instrumental music enhances your prayer
experience and helps you focus on God it
can be seen as a way to glorify God
through your prayers here's the bottom
line God just wants to hear from you he
wants you to talk with him and so if if
that music in the background is helpful
by all means I say use it you know
there's nowhere in the Bible that
forbids playing instrumental music as
long as it doesn't go against the Lord
while you're praying ultimately the
decision to pray with instrumental music
in the background is a matter of
personal preference and what helps you
to connect with God best but whether
you're driving down the street whether
you're standing up and praying whether
you're walking through the grocery store
and you're you're talking with God as
you're walking through the store he
wants to hear from you God cares more
about the condition of your heart than
you know whether or not you're listening
to music as you're praying to him or
whether or not you're driving as you're
praying to him or you're walking through
the store and praying to him he wants
you to come to him and talk to him as a
friend and establish that relationship
with them don't stop praying continue
praying and pray and ask God to help you
to even speak with him in those silent
moments because that is that is key too
you know you're not always going to have
music right there be able to speak with
God even without the music pray and ask
him to help you with that
amen preach it brother
that is the truth praise God the Lord is
ready and never busy to hear from you uh
your friends may say hey call you later
I'm on another call can I call you later
oh I Have Nots but God is readily
available thank you Jason what a
blessing I was blessed and of course we
want to hear from you as well we want
you to feel comfortable there's no
question too simple nor to hide we want
to hear from you what is in your heart
what the Lord is putting in your heart
and as you develop your relationship
with Christ and you're studying and want
to know more and understand because we
don't want anything between you and our
savior send in your commentary questions
you can text it to 1618-228-397
seven five one six one eight two two
eight three nine seven five or you can
send it through Instagram at 3abn
underscore official 3abn underscore
official that's the three number three a
b n underscore official and of course
your emails Bible QA at
3abn.tv bible QA at 3abn dot TV so all
those means are available 24 hours so
whenever you can't sleep send us your
comment and your questions so right now
Shelly this is the question for you I'm
often reminded of and referred to
scriptures about trusting God but how do
I actually put my faith and trust in God
Michael from Michigan he sent his email
and wants to know actually trust is the
foundation for Faith you know the Bible
tells us sin at Proverbs 3 5 and 6 to
trust in the Lord with all of her
heartly not our on our own understanding
and he will direct our paths what we
have to understand true belief is trust
unbelief is a refusal to trust so
believing is a verb it's an action it's
it's how we arrive at trust unbelief is
also a verb it is a refusal
to have trust let me read you first John
5 9-13 this is a wake-up call
the Bible says first John 5 9-13 if we
receive the witness of men the witness
of God is greater we receive the witness
of Men We believe that a plane will fly
and we trust it when we get on there
that the pilot is going to fly but the
witness of God is greater for this is
the witness of God which he attested or
has testified of his son
he who believes in the son
has the witness of himself he who does
not believe God has made him a liar when
you look at this word and you think oh
it's too good to be true God can't mean
that this is who I am if I accept Christ
we're calling God a liar you know and I
mean that's a wake-up call is it not so
what I love I'm gonna I just this isn't
necessarily on topic but I'm going to
read it
my favorite person it says he does not
believe God's made him a liar because
he's not believed the testimony God has
given of his son here it is this is the
testimony that God has given us eternal
life and that life is in his son he who
has the son has life he who does not
have the son does not have life so if
you are in Christ you can trust that you
have eternal life see Faith requires a
confidence that God is who he claims to
be that God is all-powerful God is love
he's all-powerful he does everything for
our Eternal benefit God is consistent
and you know if you read the Bible with
the right lens you will find that the
Bible the Old Testament the same God in
the Old Testament is the god who is the
same in the new Malachi 3 6 I am the
Lord I change not Hebrews 13 8 Jesus is
the same yesterday today and forever
James 1 17 he's The Giver of every good
and perfect gift in whom there is no
shadow of turning he never turns away
from his righteousness so to have true
faith you've got to trust God make him
the object of your faith and then see
his promises as an opportunity to
exercise your faith what happens if you
read the Bible carefully the historical
evidence of God's faithfulness to those
old Covenant people you know we read I
used to read and think God's scary no no
no it took him 850 years nearly to to
send the tribe of Judah into Babylonian
captivity he was so patient so lean not
on your own understanding lean on what
the word of God says the more you learn
about his character your identity in
Christ you will know that the
exceedingly great and precious promises
are yours in Christ and the I always say
little word little faith you it Faith
depends on your knowledge of the word of
God Amen thank you Shelley yes our God
is in the all-powerful and always loving
and consistent God that we serve so next
question ladies and gentlemen John Desi
are you ready I'm gonna shoot you this
question it comes from Canada through
text and I want to thank Cheryl for
sending in your question it has been
suggested that post-infirmity had to do
with his vision could this be from when
he was confronted by Jesus on the road
to Damascus and Blinded By The Glory of
Jesus
hmm question well it is a good question
I would say that your suggestion is a
very good possibility but the Bible does
not reveal that
so let's go look at a few verses to see
if there is evidence somewhat evidence
for it being something with his vision
Galatians chapter 6 verse 11
uh it is written it says see what large
letters I have written to you with my
own hand
and it is evident also that Paul had
help in doing the actual writing but
here he's saying see what large letters
I have written with my own hand now in
Galatians chapter 4 verse 13 through 15
notice the wording here you know that
because of physical infirmity I preached
the gospel to you at the first
And my trial which was in my flesh you
did not despise or reject but you
received me as an angel of God even as
Christ Jesus
and then it says what then was the
blessing you enjoyed for I bear you you
witness that if possible you have
plucked out your own eyes and given them
to me so there seems to be a somewhat
evidence that it was his vision even
though that's not made clear either
and whether or not it was because of
that Vision he had with Christ or this
other one here that we're going to read
in second Corinthians chapter 12 verse
7-10 unless I should be exalted above
measure by the abundance of the
revelations a thorn in the flesh was
given to me a messenger of Satan to buff
at me lest I be exalted above measure
concerning this thing I pleaded with the
Lord three times that it might depart
from me and he said to me
my grace is sufficient for you for my
strength is made perfect in weakness
therefore most gladly I would rather
boast in my infirmities that the power
of Christ May rest upon me therefore I
take pleasure in infirmities in
reproaches in needs in persecutions in
distresses for Christ's sake for when I
am weak then I am strong
so it could be a possibility that it was
that first encounter with Jesus but the
Bible does not make that clear so we
have to leave it at that
Point thank you very much amen uh Jason
Bradley
shakina shakaina I'm sorry Jamaica and
she's from Jamaica and she's sending an
email so it says this way we raised our
17 year old son in the Seventh Day
Adventist Church my husband Anaya tried
our very best to show him the right way
in Jesus only
he's now very rebellious disrespectful
to me and his dad what did we do wrong
he doesn't even regard that he's from a
Christian home or God himself will we be
punished for his behavior
Shekinah you know your question really
hits home for me my mother she raised me
in The Seventh-Day Adventist Church and
she instilled solid Christian values in
me and I decided to go astray at the age
of 14 and I didn't come back to the
church until about the age of 28 27 28
somewhere around there
but you know I I just want to say this
I'm one I'm so sorry to hear about your
challenges uh in in your son with your
son's behavior and raising him and all
of that stuff but it's important to
remember that while you can instill
those wonderful values in your child
ultimately he has to make the decision
to follow Christ and that is so
important the Bible offers guidance on
parenting and individual responsibility
Proverbs chapter 22 verse 6 says train
up a child in the way he should go and
when he is old he will not depart from
it as a parent you're responsible for
providing a Godly upbringing for your
children you've done your part by
raising him in The Seventh-Day Adventist
Church and instilling those Christian
values in him and teaching him about
Jesus continue to pray for him continue
to pour out that love on him as well
Ezekiel chapter 18 verse 20 says the
soul who sins shall die the son shall
not bear the guilt of the father nor the
father bear the guilt of the son the
righteousness of the righteous shall be
upon himself and the wickedness of the
wicked shall be upon himself each person
is accountable for their own choices and
actions and so while you may have guided
your son he ultimately again has to make
his own decisions it's not our job to
convict that's the holy spirit's job our
job is to teach and to pray for people
and and all of that stuff uh there
Proverbs chapter 15 verse 1. it says a
soft answer turns away wrath but a harsh
word stirs up anger in dealing with your
son's rebellious Behavior it's important
to maintain open communication even in
challenging moments you will not be
punished for your son's Behavior God
understands that each person has to make
their own decision and as parents you
can continue to pray for him continue to
pour out your love on him and you know
we will lift your son up in prayer as
well but I want you to know that God
wants to spend eternity with your son
even more than you want him to spend
eternity with Christ he wants to spend
eternity with your son so rest assured
in that and continue to lift him up in
prayer never stop continue praying
there's power in the prayers of a mother
amen hallelujah and you are a living
testimonial yeah and thank you so much
for your email thank you because you're
representing so many families today and
to All Families just continue to trust
in God in all his ways okay now Shirley
Quinn are you ready I'm ready I hope so
because uh
barthelemy from Saint Lucia sent this
text in let's go Ephesians 4 4 tells us
there's one Spirit John 4 24 tells us
God is Spirit yes second Corinthians 3
17 speaking of Jesus tells us the Lord
is the spirit John 15 26 tells us the
comforter is the spirit of Truth the
Holy Spirit don't these show that God is
one and he
exists in spirit thank you ah
bartholomeath this is a complicated
question to answer very quickly but let
me just Begin by saying this I agree
with all the scriptures obviously you
have listed the Bible however God
provided 58 scripture passages that show
one God is three persons the godhead is
three persons let me give you two
examples Matthew 28 19. Jesus said go
therefore and make this Disciples of all
the nations baptizing them in the name
of the father and of the son and of the
Holy Spirit second Corinthians 13 14
says the grace of our Lord Jesus Christ
the love of the father or the love of
God and the communion of the Holy Spirit
be with you all you see the godhead the
Bible presents the godhead as three
persons of identical nature who make up
one God now you say how's that possible
it is God the father son and spirit
our formula you know if you think if you
think of it this way God the father plus
God the son plus God the Holy Spirit
you've got three Gods haven't you it's
God the Father Son and Holy Spirit not
one plus one plus one but one times one
times one equals one one to the third
power in Genesis 2 24 God uses the same
formula of multiplication when he says
that a man shall leave his father and
mother be joined to his wife and that
one times one when they join together
when they are one in thought and purpose
they are one flesh so the Bible presents
that all three persons of the godhead
were and are active in the Plan of
Salvation of Grace that was given to us
before the time began Jesus said in John
4 18 16-18 I will pray the father so we
hear we see Jesus praying to the father
and he the father will give you another
helper in the Greek alos paracletos
which means a person who is just like me
that he may abide with you forever the
spirit of Truth in the world cannot
receive because it neither sees him nor
knows him but you know him for he dwells
in you and he will be with you I will
not leave you as an orphans I will come
to you wait what does that mean
Ephesians 3 17 says that Christ lives in
our hearts by faith through the holy
spirit because right now he's in heaven
at the right hand of the Throne of the
father in the short time I have let me
just say this
John 17 1-26 is the longest recorded
prayer of Jesus he prayed for himself
this is right before he goes to the
Cross he prayed for himself he prayed
for his disciples and he prayed for all
the future generations and what he is
praying is that they would believe on
him for eternal life now
Jesus intercession to the father
as he is praying for others proves that
Jesus is a separate person from the
father does it not yes guess what
he is our high priest now he intercedes
for us all but just like Jesus
intercession proved when he's praying to
the father there are two different
entities the spirit
intercedes for us and likewise this
proves his distinct personhood Romans 8
26 says likewise the spirit also helps
in our weaknesses for we do not know
what we should pray for as we are but
the spirit himself makes intercession
for us with groanings which cannot be
uttered that's a brief answer to a
complicated Christian wow thank you
praise the Lord for all these scriptures
um it's wonderful to have that reference
so ladies and gentlemen we have the last
question of this hour and this is from
Carlene and she sent in an email
10 days they get ready to tend to this I
have always heard that the high priest
had a rope tied around him that was used
to pull him out from the most holy place
in the event he died while there
recently during a study it was stated
that there is no scriptural evidence to
support this teaching about the use of
the Rope can you please clarify if
there's anything in scripture to support
this teaching Carlene asks thank you
Carlene when I first heard that when I
was younger I was like wow that's
amazing that's wonderful and it seems
logical that if the high priest is there
in the presence of God and has some
unconfessed sin that he could not
survive he would be struck dead
but your question is is there any
scriptural support for this teaching no
there's not you can go from Genesis to
Revelation you do not see specific
scriptural support for this this is
something that has started among the
Jewish people somewhere around the
Middle Ages and it has been brought into
Christianity it sounds logical but
there's no scriptural support for this
let's go to Leviticus chapter 16 verses
one through four to see the seriousness
of this uh now the Lord spoke to Moses
after the death of the two sons of Aaron
when they offered profane fire before
the Lord and died and the Lord said to
Moses tell Aaron
your brother not to come at just any
time into the holy place inside the veil
before the mercy seat which is on the
ark lest he die for I will appear in the
cloud above The Mercy Seat thus Aaron
shall come into the holy place with the
blood of a young bull as a sin offering
and of a ram as a burnt offering he
shall put the holy linen tunic and the
linen trousers on his body he shall be
girded with a linen Sash and with the
linen turban he shall be attired These
Are Holy garments therefore he shall
wash his body in water and put them on
they will say a very strict
um time and a very a time that was
dangerous for the high priest to go in
there Hebrews chapter 9 verse 6 and 7
says now when these things had been thus
prepared the priests always went into
the first part of the Tabernacle
performing the services but on yeah into
the second part that is the most holy
place the high priest went alone alone
once a year not without blood which he
offered for himself and for the people's
sins committed in ignorance so Leviticus
chapter 16 verse 6 Aaron shall offered
the bull as a sin offering which is for
himself and make atonement for himself
and for his house before he goes into
the most holy place so there is no
scripture support for the idea that a
rope was tied around his ankle there are
also some ideas that there was one
around his waist and that as he was
ministering in there uh if he's happened
to die they could pull him out because
only the high priest could go in there
so we don't have scripture support for
this
and uh I I did read something that says
it was a little difficult to even
attempt to do this with a rope because
the veil was three feet thick
wow incredible we surely have enjoyed
our time together here in the studio but
we're gonna take a pause for a moment
please do not go away we have important
information to share with you we will be
right back
if you're enjoying our 3abian Bible q a
then tell your friends each Monday will
bring you a fresh program answering the
Bible questions you send us using God's
holy word to shed light on those texts
that seem difficult to understand to
have your questions answered on a future
program just email them to us at bibleqa
at 3abn.tv that's Bible QA at 3abn.tv
you may also text your questions to
618-228-3975 that's
618-228-3975 be sure to include your
name and where you live and then watch
3ab in Bible q a for answers from God's
word
very well well we would like to say
thank you and I want to thank you all
could you please take the time and share
a few words whatever yours absolutely
you know we we said that we would pray
for Shekinah and her son and I want to
do so right now dear heavenly father
Lord we just want to lift up Shekinah
her husband and her son father help them
Father be with her son help him to turn
towards you and surrender his life fully
to you and be with all the parents
around the world father as they raise
their kids up help them to raise them in
your ways father we thank you for
hearing this prayer and we thank you for
answering it Lord and working mightily
in their life in Jesus name we pray amen
amen
Shelley and I just want to say please
remember that God wants you in the
Kingdom even more than you want to be in
the Kingdom he loves you he wants to be
your father and you can trust him with
all of your heart amen amen I want to
encourage everyone to continue studying
the holy scriptures God has so much to
teach us he is just anxiously waiting
for us to open the holy scriptures
asking God to help us understand because
we're living in a time when the Holy
scriptures are going to be our anchor
and our strength in time of trial and
difficulties that is just coming upon us
we are living in the last days and is
now more important than ever to study
God's word amen and may the joy of the
Lord be your strength right so we thank
you for joining us God bless you thank
you for your comments your questions
contact your friends and family and
share about this program so they too can
have the opportunity to share what is
prompting their hearts in question well
see you next Edition
thank you
[Music]
foreign